bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
des écrans pliables une technologie qui
intéresse de plus en plus les fabricants
lg a présenté aux crs sont 2018 un écran
enroulable alors sur un format télé mais
si on fait sur un grand ferment on peut
le faire sur un plus petit format
lenovo a déjà représenté par le passé
aussi des écrans pliables de son côté
samsung s'attelle à la tâche pour sortir
ce qui est pur est en tout cas un futur
galaxy x alors à quoi pourrait
ressembler nos écrans dans le futur
c'est ce qu'on va regarder dans cette
vidéo
[Musique]
avant toute chose dites moi ce que vous
en pensez est ce que vous pensez que ces
écrans pliables pourrait sortir
est ce qu'on pourra y retrouver sur nos
futures générations de smart phone est
ce que pour vous c'est une bonne chose
mais est ce qu'on va dans le bon sens
mark et moi tout son commentaire
j'aime bien prendre la température et
voir ce que vous en pensez moi je suis
persuadé qu'on va plus avoir plusieurs
objets un smartphone une monde connecté
à un ordinateur
et tout ça qui fonctionnent ensemble
vieille claude à mon avis ça va être
différent
on va avoir un seul objet qui va
centraliser toutes les informations et
qui servirent un petit peu de tout
maintenant quelle forme ça va prendre
à quoi ça va ressembler encore un petit
peu obscur parce qu'effectivement on n'a
pas tout de suite toutes les
technologies donc c'est un petit peu
difficile de se projeter
on a déjà quelques indices on voit ce
qu'a fait samsung avec le decs l'idée
d'utiliser la puissance de son
smartphone comme un ordinateur
ça va dans le bon sens d'ailleurs c'est
ce qu'a fait aussi razer avec le projet
linda donc à mon sens les smartphones
tels qu'on les connaît vont vraiment
être le centre de notre vie numérique
on aura peut-être plus d'ordinateurs
sauf pour des choses qui demandent
vraiment une puissance énorme
on devrait voir arriver bientôt des
smartphones avec 10 gigas de ram des
bêtes de compet
donc ça va vraiment dans ce sens là en
terme de puissance mais d'un point de
vue écran qu'est ce qui va arriver à
l'avenir on va très bien qu'on vous des
écrans toujours plus grand du coût des
smartphones qui pourront remplacer des
tablettes mais sur des formats compacts
qu'ils peuvent tenir dans la poche
l'idée tout ça pour solutionner le
problème c'est effectivement d'avoir des
écrans qui peuvent se replier à quoi va
ressembler ces écrans pliables de quelle
façon est ce que les différentes marques
conçoivent ce que pourrait être en tout
cas ces produits qu'est ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui comme un faux qu'est ce qui
pourrait sortir demain c'est
effectivement tout ce qu'on va regarder
ensemble
l'idée des constructeurs c'est d'imposer
un nouveau standard aujourd'hui on
connaît effectivement des smartphones je
dis bon bah c'est des choses un peu
classique
c'est la première génération de
smartphones même si avant effectivement
on avait des téléphones à clapet même si
on voit que ça évolue
même si on bat pour garder plus grand
écran l'un va se diriger sur tout autre
chose
un produit qui aura plusieurs fonctions
et justement l'enjeu pour les
constructeurs pour les marques essaient
d'être le premier sur ce marché d'être
le leader et d'imposer un nouveau
standard comme ça tous les autres vont
devoir suivre un petit peu mais le
premier innover c'est lui vraiment qu'il
va remporter la palme
on voit effectivement que les
constructeurs travaillent sur différents
prototypes lenovo avait d'ailleurs
présenté par le passé l'idée du
grande tablette que vous pourriez
replier et qui vous ferait un smartphone
c'est à dire en gros à smartphones où
vous auriez d'écran de chaque côté et
lorsque vous l'ouvrirez y est vous
auriez une seule et grande tablette
il ya également un projet qui pourrait
être intéressant c'est l'idée d'avoir un
grand smartphone qui pourrait se replier
et qu'on pourrait utiliser comme un
bracelet ou comme une montre connectés
on va très bien qu'avec ça on va plus
vers du web elle va effectivement un
objet de téléphonie qu'on va pouvoir
porter sur soi et qui sera facile
d'accès facile d'utilisation donc pas
forcément un produit qu'on aura dans la
poche
samsung travaille depuis 2001 sur un
écran pliable qui pourrait intégrer à
leur smartphone le samsung galaxy x on a
beaucoup parlé il alimente les rumeurs
on a pensé un temps qu'il pourrait
sortir en 2018 alors peut-être encore
fin 2018 mais on se dirigerait peut-être
probablement plusieurs 2019 si vous
voulez pour l'instant ça me saoule n'a
pas infirmé travailler dessus mais n'a
pas non plus confirmé de date de sortie
ils ont effectivement pour l'instant il
n'était pas encore prêt ce qu'on sait en
tout cas c'est que samsung aurait
présenté deux prototypes de ce que
pourrait être le samsung galaxy x à des
partenaires le premier ça serait un
écran pliable qui se refermerait à
l'intérieur comme un livre ce qui fait
que une fois refermée vous auriez les
deux écrans face à face et rien sur
l'extérieur alors pour l'utiliser comme
un smartphone ce sera un peu compliqué
ce qu'il faudrait faire dans ce cas là
c'est rajouter encore un autre écran à
l'extérieur donc à mon avis on parlait
vraiment le sens de ce produit parce que
l'idée du smartphone avec un écran
pliable
c'est effectivement que lorsque vous le
replier vous pouvez encore avoir les
deux écrans donc si vous le replier par
l'intérieur on mettant ensuite en autres
écrans à l'extérieur on perd un petit
peu le sens et encore le problème que
vous avez que ça c'est que ça va
augmenter le coût ça va forcément coûter
beaucoup plus cher parce qu'en plus
d'avoir un seul grand écran vous allez
avoir un autre écran son extérieur
donc si vous voulez des écrans de
qualité ça va coûter tout de suite très
très cher et à mon avis on perd
l'essence même de ce genre de produits
il aurait présenté un deuxième produit
vous effectivement lorsque vous le repli
reggae vous auriez les deux écrans à
l'extérieur ça mon avis a beaucoup plus
de sens pourquoi parce que l'idée
l'essence même de ce genre de chose d'
écran pliable c'est d'avoir un seul
écran et lorsque vous l'ouvrez un très
grand écran donc à mon sens sur ce genre
de choses
l'écran au dos ce raid est activé
lorsque vous l'utiliseriez parce que si
vous le tenez dans la main faudrait pas
appuie sur des touches sans le vouloir
au dos maintenant l'inconvénient de ce
genre de produit c'est effectivement les
coques de protection puisque les écrans
de toute façon vont être fragile si vous
le posez si vous le faites tomber ou
vous risquez de l'endommager très
rapidement donc il faut le protéger donc
lorsque vous le protège et vous ne
pourrez pas forcément l'ouvrir comme
vous le voudrez donc à voir également
chez les constructeurs de coqs pour nous
faire des coques amovibles qui vont très
bien s'intégrer avec ce genre de produit
sans imagine très bien que ces choses
qui pourraient venir dans le futur est
en tout cas c'est vraiment très très
très intéressant d'ailleurs ça me sauve
aurait présenté des smartphones avec des
écrans de 7,3 pour ces infos sur samsung
nous viennent du journal korea investors
d'ailleurs au cs si vous avez suivi mes
vidéos vous avez vu que zte a présenté
un smartphone avec un grand écran qui
pouvaient se plier sauf qu'en réalité ce
n'est pas un seul et grand écran qui se
plie ce sont deux écrans avec une
charnière centrale
l'inconvénient effectivement c'est que
lorsqu'il est ouvert vous avez un grand
écran avec une grosse bordure au milieu
grosse bordure noire est moche qu'il y a
un peu cassé truc donc ça effectivement
c'est un peu un coup d'épée dans l'eau
on voit que c'est un peu raté par contre
ce qui est super intéressant là dessus
c'est qu'on va vraiment que les
tendances se dessinent vraiment sur ces
grands écrans pour pour replier sur la
modularité d'ailleurs au pot le
constructeur chinois travaillerait
également sur un projet pour sortir un
smartphone avec un écran pliable une
fois refermé ce sera un smartphone et
une fois ouvert ce serait une grande
tablette au pot d'ailleurs qui pourrait
arriver sur le marché européen dès 2018
donc on voit très bien que cette
tendance s'accentue s'accélère et que
les grands acteurs commencent à
travailler dessus
les grands acteurs pour l'instant apple
n'a pas trop d'informations là-dessus sk
peut lire et se positionner dessus pour
l'instant rien n'est moins sûr microsoft
également avec son surface phone projet
andromeda qui pourrait être un
smartphone d'une toute nouvelle
génération avec un grand écran pliable
donc à travers toutes ces rumeurs on
peut se demander effectivement à quoi
vont ressembler ces smartphones du futur
quelles sont les nouvelles tendances qui
se dessinent à mon sens il ya quatre
projets qui sont les plus probables
le tout premier c'est effectivement le
smartphone avec l'écran qui se replie à
l'intérieur comme un livre ce qui fait
que lorsque vous l'ouvrez vous avez un
grand bouquin que vous pouvez lire donc
effectivement l'inconvénient c'est qu'il
faudrait un écran plus donc ça mon avis
on oublie le deuxième qui paraît le plus
probable c'est effectivement quelque
chose de fermé avec un écran sur devant
et lorsque vous ouvrez vous avez le
grand écran qui se présente d'une seule
et même parti ça ça paraît beaucoup plus
logique
après effectivement falloir que les os
soit adaptatif qui reconnaissent
l'ouverture
directement et qui vous propose un
affichage complètement adaptée ça ça ne
paraît pas non plus le plus compliqué
est une fois pliée l'écran arrière
c'était complètement désactivé troisième
projet vous pourriez avoir d'écran
roulable comme ce qu'a présenté lg aux
crs c'est-à-dire un écran qui rentre
dans un espèce de tubes et ensuite vous
pouvez le faire ressortir et avoir un
grand écran ça me paraît assez
intéressant c'est à dire un tube qui
serait quand même assez grand qui
abriterait votre micro votre
appareil-photo pourquoi pas un capteur
pour déverrouiller au niveau de
l'empreinte digitale pourquoi pas des
caméras trou dax comme fayçal et on peut
imaginer des choses comme ça et je vous
dit quelque chose qui prendrait une
taille minimale et une fois ouvert vous
auriez un grand écran quelque chose de
très pratique et très sympa il a quatre
et l'hypothèse selway riebel cd chose
sur lequel on va aller mais peut-être un
peu plus tard encore c'est à dire avoir
un device que vous pouvez utiliser comme
une montre connectés il va pouvoir
s'ouvrir après avec un grand écran soit
qu'elles vous allez pouvoir pianoter
après effectivement on peut aller encore
plus loin et imaginer une projection
holographique se passer d'un écran on
peut imaginer normalement de choses donc
là on a encore beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup plus loin dans le futur mais
c'est des choses qui risque d'arriver
alors quelle sera la technologie à ce
moment là ça sent encore un peu un point
d'interrogation mais on voit que de
toute façon à mon sens après ces écrans
pliables
on va aller vers des choses qui seront
davantage dématérialisé donc du r&b tout
ça s'arrête encore un peu flou
aujourd'hui chose qui paraît la plus
probable dans l'immédiat c'est
effectivement d'avoir ces grands écrans
pliables
donc l'enjeu pour les marques là dessus
c'est très clairement d'être le premier
d'imposer un standard pour pouvoir être
leader de cette future révolution et
attention à ne pas se tromper c'est pour
ça que pour l'instant on voit
effectivement que les constructeurs ils
vont doucement on voit que samsung
cherche un peu à prendre la température
auprès de ses partenaires pour voir quel
est le projet qui remporterait
l'unanimité et qui aurait plus de
chances d'avoir un succès commercial
parce que lorsque vous passez des années
en recherche et développement sur ce
genre de produit
et si vous vous plantez et que le
concurrent lui remporté les 1000 vous ai
perdu beaucoup de temps beaucoup
d'argent et c'est très mauvais pour
votre entreprise
donc faut vraiment arriver avec un
projet auquel vos partenaires croient
ils sur lequel vous avez une chance
vraiment d'être leader sur le marché
au final qu'est ce que c'est une rumeur
qu'est ce que c'est prototype nous
disent ils permettent vraiment une fois
de plus de sentir ce qui peut se passer
de sentir ce qui va arriver on va très
clairement que l'un d'entre eux se
projeter idron regarder dans le futur
des écrans pliables demain des objets
matérialisé après demain ça c'est super
intéressant donc on va encore en parler
dans les temps à venir
je vous invite d'ailleurs à vous abonner
pour rester connecté pour ne rien louper
de toutes ces rumeurs de toute
l'actualité de tous les produits je vais
tester
parce que je vais beaucoup bouger encore
dans les temps à venir je vous invite
comme d'habitude bien évidemment amener
ces des jolies pouces a marqué tous vos
commentaires toutes vos questions toutes
vos suggestions toutes vos idées
merci beaucoup parce qu'il est toujours
plus en plus nombreux à être présents
sur la chaîne je vous dis à très bientôt
n'oubliez pas vous êtes les meilleurs à
très bientôt portez vous bien
prenez soin de vous ciao ciao
[Musique]